este vídeo es una introducción al
lanzador de proyectiles es un proyecto
que pueden construir y vamos a llevarlos
paso a paso para que puedan hacerlo en
los siguientes dos vídeos pero primero
vamos a enseñarles algunas cosas que
puede hacer ajustándolo a 60 grados y
llevándolo a la posición número 4
lanzamos la pelota de ping pong
directamente al bote de basura a ese se
fue un poco chueco pero lo podemos
intentar de nuevo entonces el lanzador
nos permite hacer los cálculos para que
el movimiento de un proyectil cobre vida
podrán tener una noción de cómo hacer el
lanzador de proyectiles más precisos y
también obtendrán una noción de cómo los
distintos materiales se lanzan de forma
diferente como por ejemplo estas pelotas
no funcionan muy bien comparadas con las
pelotas de ping pong y con papel no hay
precisión entonces esto abre la
oportunidad para que tengamos mucho que
hablar sobre todo esto por ejemplo aquí
una vez que tenemos el proyectil con
ciertos ángulo
y conocemos la naturaleza del proyectil
podemos tirar las latas una tras otra
con un nivel alto de precisión
y ahora tiramos la otra lata que estaba
ahí y bueno hay muchos vídeos que hablan
sobre el movimiento de un proyectil
pueden echarles un vistazo para ver cómo
hacer todos los cálculos ahora hemos
traído el lanzador a la alberca a ver si
podemos lanzar las pelotas de ping pong
al salvavidas pero si les gustó este
lanzador vean los siguientes dos vídeos
y les enseñaremos cómo hacerlo